- C'est devenu le symbole de
la résistance ukrainienne.
À Irpin p p pont sous lequel
les civils en fuite, sous
les tirs des Russes, cherchaient
à s'abriter, se tient comme
un monument tordu à la bataille,
qui  f f freiner l'avancée
des soldats de Vladimir Poutine
vers le coeur de Kiev.
"J'ai l'âme en paix, dit
le maire, d'une certaine façon,
mais autrement, c'est effrayant
parce qu'on peut voir ce qu'ils
ont fait de la ville.
La destruction que l'on voit,
c'est principalement le résultat
de notre défense de ililille.
C'est la dernière ville avant
Kiev qui a résisté et maintenu
ses défenses. C'est d'ici que
l'Ukraine a lancé une contre-
offensive contre les troupes
russes, et nous avons réussi."
"La ville héroïne" a dit
le président Zelensky.
Aujourd'hui, ses habitants
commencent à y revenir.
"Nous avons peur que les troupes
russes puissvevevevenir, dit-il.
Des informations circulent;
ça va peut-être arriver dans
deux semaines avant le 9 mai,
le jour de la victoire en
RuC'C'C'C'est une des dates
favorites du président Poutine,
alors nous avons tous peur.
Mais il faut rebâtir notre
ville, maintenant."
Les soldats russes auxquels
la ville d'Irpin a tenu tête
sont aujourd'hui remplacés par
une armée de bénévoles.
Ils brandissent de simples
pelles et balais. Si les combats
ont pris fin à Irpin, c'est ici,
à Hostomel, que sont arrivés
les troupes russes, en
s'emparant de l'aéroport.
Emma est restée chez elle,
la plupart du temps dans
la cave. Dans son jardin,
dans les rues, tout était
trop effrayant.
"Ça faisait très peur,
raconte-t-elle. Ils traitaient
tout le monde méchamment,
sans honneur. Vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer. Il y avait un homme au
marché, le directeur, il était
très gentil. Ils sont venus pour
qu'il leur ouvre le marché.
Il a hésité un peu et quand
il a ouvert la porte,
il a reçu une balle dans
la tête. Comme ça!"
Emma croyait que sa voisine
s'était mise à l'abri, hors de
la ville. Elle voulait nourrir
ses poulets quand elle a
découvert Svetlana. La dame
s'était réfugiée juste en
dessous, dans ce réduit.
Son corps ne porte aucune trace
de violence. C'est son coeur qui
n'a visiblement pas tenu
le coup.
"Personne ne sait quand c'est
arrivé, dit Emma. Elle était
très accomplie. Elle jardinait,
c'étainenenenenenene
merveilleuse, et elle est
partie."
Boris n'en pouvait plus de voir
le corps d'un jeune homme gisant
au sol, en proie aux éléments et
aux charog
"Il portait une croix",
dit-il. C'était urgent qu'il
soit enterré, il s'en est donc
chargé.
"On a mis une croix,
explique-t-il, parce qu'un
orthodoxe doit être enterré sous
une croix. Je l'ai enterré en
surface, mais il doit être mis
en terre correctement. Avoir
un prêtre qui chante
un enterrement humain."
Boris pense que c'était un
jeaiaiaiaiaiaiaiainien. Il a
interpellé l'armée à plusieurs
reprises, mais personne n'est
encore venu le réclamer.
"Je n'ai pas vérifié s'il avait
des papiers d'identification.
Peut-être, dit-il! Ils seront
toujours là. S'ils le déterrent,
ils regarderont. Je ne sais pas.
Quand je l'ai enterré,
ça tirait de tous les côtés.
Les roquettes volaient,
je n'étais pas en mesure de
chercher ses papiers.
Pour moi, c'était simplement
une personne."
Borodianka a connu sans doute
les combats les plus féroces.
C'est une des premières villes
dortoirs autour de la capitale,
qui a été visée par les frappes
aériennes, au début de
l'invasion.
Le passage des soldats russes
ici à transformer la ville en
plaie béante. Preuve, disent
les autorités, que la Russie
s'est acharnée délibérément sur
les habitations civiles :
des édifices coupés en deux par
des frappes, éventrés, noircis
par des flammes, effondrés comme
des châteaux de cartes.
Les autorités pensent que près
de 200 personnes sont restées
coincées dans les décomb
On les présume mortes.
Dans les quartiers résidentiels
comme celui-ci, à Borodianka,
qui ont été lourdement
endommagés par les bombardements
et par les combats
les opérations de recherche ont
été retardées. Il fallait
d'abord vérifier que le terrain
ne soit pas miné.
Ces hommes, les mêmes qui se
sont lancés sur les lieux de
chacune des frappes depuis pluss
pour en extirper les blessés,
travaillent aussi vite que
possible; mais avec toute
la prudence et la délicatesse
que permet la machinerie lourde
qui les assiste.
Bien qu'on cherche surtout des
cadavres, ici le chef des
services d'urgence se permet
encore d'espérer un miracle.
"Il y a trois jours, dit-il,
nous avons frappé sur les dalles
de béton, et quelque part à
l'intérieur, nous avons entendu
quelqu'un frapper en retour.
Nous avons entendu un son. C'est
pour ça qu'on commence ici,
dans cet édifice. Parce qu'il y
a encore de l'espoir que des
gens soient en vie."
Ludmilla et son mari Igor
assistent à la scène, l'estomac
noué. Ils n'ont pas bougé depuis
le début des travaux. La soeur
de Ludmilla et leur neveu sont
parmi les quatre personnes que
l'on croit ensevelies.
"Ils ont frappé avec un missil.
Un à frappé ici, et l'autre là.
Voyez."
Igor, lui, s'interdit tout
espoir.
"Nous espérons seulement pouvoir
les enterrer aujourd'hui.
Je suis désolé."
Si on ne peut plus les sauver,
eux, et tous ceux que
l'on cherche encore dans
les caves et sous les gravats,
on peut peut-être leur offrir
plus de dignité dans le repos
que dans la mort.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Borodiank